so the state's economic forum met
virtually today to discuss revenue
forecasts for the next few years
as you know less people are visiting las
vegas right now as covet cases keep
rising across the country
hector mejia is live for us on the las
vegas strip with more from that meeting
hi hector
hey there as analysts talked about those
revenue projections they pointed out
that the strip has been hit the hardest
when it comes to
casino destinations across the country
the economic forum went over a number of
revenue sources they started with
gaming taxes which as we know are a
major source for the state
since june the state's total win is down
27.2 percent
or 1.4 billion dollars in a graph
analysts projected a gradual recovery
over the next few years
the nevada gaming control board projects
8.7 billion dollars for the fiscal year
2021
for comparison that's a drop of 11.2
percent from 2020.
analysts also said that locals are
driving the slot side while
table winds are more dependent on
international visitors and we have very
few of them
the only properties near the strip still
closed are the palms
rio and the former hard rock hotel which
is being transformed into virgin las
vegas
many resorts on the strip also have
closed hotel operations during the slow
midweek days we're having a slow period
on top of the fact we don't have any
events that
pump up the business during that time
period nfr is gone
um for this year new year's i can't
imagine our new year's is going to be
anywhere near what we've experienced in
the past
and then uh january the large the large
conventions the the ces
that's not happening so i think it's
going to be a challenging couple months
and they expect the live entertainment
tax to take longer than the gaming tax
to recover and we're talking about
revenue from production shows
live entertainment headliners retail
sales have fared better than expected
and analysts also said that the
governor's announcement yesterday about
the vaccine coming to nevada is good
news for their projection models
they hope it boosts confidence and
speeds up the recovery process
reporting from the strip hector mejia 8
news now